Alys an art director and he mentioned to
us that his dream was to win an Academy
Award for art direction so we said well
you should dress as though you're ready
to get your Academy Award a dream future
let's say five years from now every
dream you want comes true what are you
doing where are you living really dating
what kind of car you driving what are
you wearing
I think my personal style is a mix match
of things I appreciate and I collect
magazines internet TV on street so I see
the the great thing about him is he has
it naturally you know like almost a
dancers stance perfect posture very
proud
he has great bone structure and he cut
in have it this is very short that's
very big I know we need to kind of make
it not quite such a difference and guys
have to start to realize that this the
whole like super short on the sides and
long on the top does not work on every
face his lips are completely destroyed
from not moisturiser II so but we used
some of my lip balm on the men and you
know that was important just to make him
look groom and the Megan lanique is very
elegant you could turn it into a Boldini
paint
anything close I often do really
extravagant evening clothes
I sell even clothes very well people
come to me looking for amazing
interesting different evening clothes
and blue that kind of blue velvet is one
of my my favorites I wear that actually
myself we can literally call that ah
cerulean so we decided this is what
you're dreaming of wearing when you
accept your Academy Award for our
direction on blah blah blah film now
stick the chin up just a touch you're
very arrogant you're a Spanish Duke
you're the coolest [ __ ] thing in the
whole world just be proud
think of something slightly bad I think
showing off the ink the tuxedo and
showing up like these we are definitely
attached a lot of respect and you know
interesting people if you have like a
Tom Ford to see the pony is gonna be the
best to achieve you ever had one thing -
we gave all these guys manicures
manicures are so important for a man
when you're on a date with a woman or
you're on a date with anybody they're
looking at your hands so a really
well-manicured pair of hands are going
to get in a lot more pairs of underwear
than a pair of hands that are really
unkempt and scary-looking so hands very
important
you